this red warning is stretching right  across the south of wales not only that  the public transport affected to the  stagecoach uh bus company stage coach of  cancel here we go bit of that  the stage stagecoach have cancelled a  lot of their bus services but big  double decker buses aren't going to be  running or just going to turn there so  we're really getting busted by the winds  great television though as always but  the advice is really to stay inside and  not risk coming to places like this it's  already turning out to be a pretty  treacherous place to be um schools also  as i mentioned disruption to those kids  learning but having said that it is half  term as of tomorrow in this part of the  world but it's really those waves that  are starting to build up worth saying  though that high tide has has passed so  in theory it should only get better from  here but you're still seeing a number of  people coming out to take the sights in  but they are being urgent